In a Chicago school, one kindergartner fretted
to a friend that he wouldn't be able to get
his spare underpants from his cubby in case
he had an accident.
Why?
Staff at the prestigious, private Catherine
Cook School had opted to deny five and six-year-olds
access to their cubbies in order to school
them on privilege.
Later, kindergartners were selectively denied
access to the playground equipment so they
might experience discrimination.
If one student did this to another, we would
rightly call it bullying.
But when parents raised concerns, the principle
told them, "Catherine Cook is a current century
progressive school.
Educators who regard themselves as socially
conscious can get so invested in agenda, that
they lose sight of the real kids in front
of them."
Look, the debate is not over whether students
should be taught about discrimination and
privilege, they should, but good teaching
requires judgment.
Kindergartners don't benefit from experiencing
violation to principles they don't yet understand.
Educators need to find responsible ways to
introduce students to our shared values.
How do you think we should teach students
about charged social issues like inequality?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds.
And be sure to "Like" and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.